dernier ajustements avant le début de
trois jours de folie Emilie Dijoux 35
ans originaire de syllaos et responsable
administrative et financière depuis 2016
le Sakifo propose un système de paiement
digital qu'elle gère et qui est
aujourd'hui utilisé par 80 % des
festivals ça se prépare des mois et des
mois en amont du festival c'est une
petite fourmilière il faut que tout soit
bien paramétré ça part du lancement au
début de la billetterie forcément vu que
tout est lié les numéros de billets et
reliés au cashless pour que les gens
puissent se faire rembourser ensuite sur
Internet là on a toute la zone
restauration donc on a les paiements
cachés ceci sur la zone restauration et
ils peuvent accepter d'autres paiements
espèces et CB aussi on a les travail
d'Émilie demande rigueur et organisation
avec le Sakifo en 10 jours près de 500
emplois directs sans créer 2 millions et
demi d'euros dépensés tout ça est validé
par les midis la grande gestionnaire les
femmes qui l'entourent la suivent les
yeux fermés elle est carré j'aime
beaucoup ça et elle m'apprend énormément
de choses j'aime sa façon qu'elle a de
m'apprendre les choses et on s'entend
bien parce que justement on a plus ou
moins la même vision des choses sur le
travail après avoir été assistante
comptage comptable responsable de la
billetterie ou encore administratrice sa
polyvalence et sa plus grande qualité la
jeune femme a grandi avec le Saco alors
la réussite de l'événement lui tient
forcément à cœur c'est un grand travail
d'équipe on se soutient tous dans les
moments de bien et moins bien et en fait
forcément si on n'est pas tous là
ensemble à s'entraider il y a pas de
festival donc ça a toujours été une
grande famille ça ne sera toujours et
c'est comme ça et c'est pour ça qu'on
aime ce festival ça qu'il faut le
marathon du Sakifo d'Emilie et toute son
équipe a débuté il y a plusieurs mois le
relâchement ce sera pour la semaine
prochaine à la fin de l'événement